in late October workers in China lined
up for quarantine then others rushed to
leave their jobs and some clashed with
police and covet protective suits
these are images of the chaos that
erupted at a Foxconn site in Zhengzhou
China where the majority of Apple's
iPhones are made
now holiday Shoppers this Christmas
season are stuck with long wait times
and apple warned its pro model shipments
would be lower than expected
so here's what led to the protests at
Foxconn and what that means for your
iPhone
foreign
the travel season for China's week-long
national day holiday began and people
hit the road
when residents return from other parts
of the country that's when covid-19
broke out in zhangzhou the virus
eventually spread to foxconn's fast
manufacturing site where the company
enforced strict coveted controls
by late October some workers were sent
to quarantine centers others were
confined to unfinished apartment
buildings nearby and they were filmed
screaming in frustration
meanwhile some employees were asked to
move out of their dorms and sleep in the
factory hallways to keep production
running
worried about catching covet on October
29th thousands of workers fled the
facility
some people boarded buses after hearing
rumors that infected employees were
being allowed to work to meet production
goals
to replace those who left recruitment
ads started popping up on November 7th
these ads promise quarantine allowances
and bonuses for people who would work
for 30 or 60 days
foreign
on November 23rd when new recruits got
angry over what they said were delayed
bonus payments and conditions at the
plant
[Applause]
to control the outrage police were
deployed beating and chasing workers
the next day many employees lined up at
a train station after taking a foxconn's
offer of fourteen hundred dollars to
leave the company also said it would
guarantee recruits would be paid in line
with official ads and blamed a computer
error for some of the pay issues
the staff shortage has added pressure to
the tech Giant's iPhone production as
Foxconn jeongzhou facility makes 85
percent of the pro lineup of iPhones
this means customers who ordered their
smartphones in October or November may
not even get it before Christmas
to see why take a look at this graph
when Apple launched the iPhone 14 pro in
September the wait time was 32 days
during the first week then it started to
decrease this is pretty typical when
there's a new launch like with the
iPhone 13 Pro but when covet hit the
jeongzhou plant in October the wait time
went up and eventually hit 37 Days by
late November which is the longest in
the product's 15-year history Apple
didn't respond to a request for comment
about the iPhone delays
meanwhile steps are being taken to
mitigate the Ripple effects of the
disruptions Foxconn has tried to
increase iPhone 14 production at other
sites in the country according to people
familiar with the matter China's rigid
covet controls among other issues have
also prompted Apple to look beyond the
mainland particularly in India and
Vietnam and this could mean in the
future many of our iPhones start coming
not from China but from other countries